[Music]
a rude awakening for a suspect alleged
to be involved in county lines and
knife crime
watching from below the home secretary
trying to refocus on her job
after nearly losing it do you like your
early only
well i think it's important you know we
have as you can see frontline officers
day in day out doing this kind of stuff
showing that they're being supported
definitely but actually prioritizing
this kind of work yeah
this is this is this is law and order
but is there law and order within the
government
last week a report found the home
secretary bullied staff and broke the
ministerial code but the prime minister
overruled saying the code hadn't been
broken
and she could keep her job pretty patel
said she was sorry that her behaviour
upset people but if she hadn't broken
the code
what exactly was she apologizing for you
have
apologized um but do you accept the
findings of the report
that you were bullying and that you
broke the ministerial code
well first of all i have unreservedly
apologized for
what was published last week in terms of
the reports finding i've not seen the
report
so i can't call you you've seen the
comments that he made that you broke the
ministerial code
and that you were you what your behavior
would be deemed as bullying to accept
those findings well
first of all i have given an unreserved
apology about that
and it's important to recognize in terms
of the code that the prime minister
is the arbiter of that code and he makes
the judgments accordingly as well i just
wonder what your view is
my view is on the record my view is
absolutely on the record and i've given
which is an unreserved apology to
anybody
that has been upset by anything that has
taken what are you apologizing for what
behavior of yours are you apologizing
for
people felt upset and that it's
important if people
felt upset by what if people felt upset
by
expressions of frustration um
specifically
that has been highlighted by alex allen
and i've been very clear about that i've
given an unreserved apology and i will
continue to do
the way in which you expressed your
frustration absolutely
you're allowed to be direct with people
well the way in which frustrations have
been expressed
today the prime minister wrote to his
team saying there is a particular duty
on ministers and permanent secretaries
to create
jointly across government culture which
is professional
respectful focused and ambitious for
change and in which there's no place
for bullying but this isn't enough to
satisfy the shadow home secretary
he has effectively turned a blind eye
when an independent report came across
his desk
saying clearly that the home secretary
had breached the ministerial code
now the home secretary shows no remorse
and seems to be effectively blaming
the victims of bullying for what
happened her position is completely
untenable
25 million pounds in additional funding
has been put aside this year to tackle
county lines
in september a national drive led to a
thousand arrests and 1
500 children being safeguarded it's
absolutely shocking i mean children
you know the same age as our own kids
basically that are involved and such
into all of this it is devastating
pretty patel hopes her efforts in
policing will deflect criticism
elsewhere
but there are suggestions the prime
minister is frustrated with the home
office's failure to stem migration
across the channel
and the woman he spared in november
could still be shuffled out of her role
come the new year jason farrell sky news